Purgatory is the belief that when you
die as a Believer baptized in Christ but
you have sins that have not been
purged right because either you haven't
walk completely in Union with the
spirit and haven't confessed them then
when you die the Lord will then allow
you to
experience pration purifying you and
cleansing you before you enter Christ's
Heavenly presence now let me show you
something that the spirit I believe and
I pray I'm not speaking
presumptuously showed me how
Purgatory doesn't undermine the perfect
sacrifice of our Lord Jesus Christ I'm
being honest with you I don't remember
anywhere seeing anyone using these so
how does the Holy Spirit illuminate you
he'll either illuminate you through
human vessels with wisdom he's given
them to give you or he'll illuminate you
right there as you read he'll just come
to you or as you're teaching boom he
illuminates you on the spot there are
people who believe in purat there are
Protestants who believe in a form of
purgatory postmortem pration like Jerry
walls a Protestant philosopher who
destroys Calvinism glory to Jesus Christ
and I've been told that even Orthodox
have a form of purgatory called toll
houses you see what happens when you say
to the Holy Spirit I yield I submit
convict me to repent of my man-made
traditions and stop forcing my view on
the Bible and try trying to put God in
my box and enable me to allow the Bible
speak and accept whatever is true and
repent of error when you pray that
prayer from your heart then the holy
spirit will start revealing things
because the spirit will give you the
desires of your heart if you insist this
can't be true the spirit will convict
you but if you resist then he hands you
over all right you insist then here you
go but when you ask the spirit please
Perfect my Theology and Purify Me
perfect me in holiness show me my and
I've been praying that since I've come
to the faith even as a staunch calvinist
I would pray that Holy Spirit please
save me from sin make me pure and holy
so I don't shame the Lord and show me
where I'm wrong and when you pray that
from your heart he starts showing you
that shows you that postm morning
pration does not nullify the work of
Jesus
Christ it's because of Jesus Christ that
he procured your postm morm purgation in
other words had it not been for
Jesus right and his life and death there
would be no postm morning purgation you
go straight to hell so instead of seeing
it as an attack against the work of
Christ it's actually inclusive of the
work of Christ because Jesus earned by
his life and death your salvation your
sanctification your P purification even
postmortem pration it's all in included
in the work of Jesus he procured these
blessings but if you've been taught
Calvinism and hatred for the ancient
Traditions you're going to say the work
of Christ is nullified by Purgatory it's
an insult blasphemy against the L no no
no when you say holy spirit open my
heart and my mind and my ears to your
voice and understand then he will show
you no had it not been for Jesus Christ
listen now had it not been for Jesus
Christ his life and death
there would be no
sanctification
purification discipline and
transformation you'd get what you
deserve but because of the love of Jesus
in his life and death he's now procured
these Graces which includes the grace of
postmortem purgation that's how you're
supposed to see it and I'm now going to
show you where scripture confirms this
Isaiah 6 vers Isaiah 6 ver 5-7 here it
is here's purgatory or purgation because
Purgatory means to be purged of your
filth and sin to stand worthy before God
here you go Isaiah 6 verses 5 to7 and I
said woe is me for I am lost for I am a
man of unclean lips and I dwell in the
midst of a people of unclean lips for my
eyes have seen my physical eyes are
seeing the king Jehovah host appearing
at a visible shape in a visible form and
a visible body with a visible robe
Seated on a visible throne and he
notices his unworthiness I'm unclean so
then what does God do then flew one of
the seraphim to me having in his hand a
burning cold so it's burning hot which
he had taken with tongues from The Altar
and he touched my mouth now notice he
didn't feel
pain he didn't feel his mouth burning
with pain and Agony the burning coal
purged his sin without harming him and
said behold this has touched your lips
your guilt is taken away and your sin
forgiven
what how can a burning coal from the
altar where sacrifices are offered Purge
his mouth of his un cleanly
cleanliness Purge him of his sin making
him worthy to stand before God you see
without Holiness you cannot see God so
you had to be
purged by that Co a burning flaming coal
that did not harm him or hurt him but
purged him cleansing him of his filth to
stand before the Lord in a worthy manner
but this is the same Isaiah who in
Isaiah 53 says that the servant bore my
sins took up my sins bore my iniquities
and made intercession for me by offering
his soul as a guilt offering so how can
the coal Purge him of his sin when he
says in Isaiah 53 it's a servant that
takes up my sin Bears my sin offers his
soul as a guilt offering to atone for my
sins and makes intercession for me
because this
purgation is part of the work of the
servant that procures the grace of the
coal purging him of his
sin we got it or no
did we get it or
no Isaiah 65
to7 let me know before I move
on but Isaiah 53 it says the servant
offers his soul as a guilt offering and
he bore the sins of many and the Lord
laid on him the iniquity of a all my
sins
included so if the servant is bearing
your sins taking your punishment to
bring about your forgiveness and
salvation and he bore your sins and he
intercedes for you and that's how you're
forgiven then why would you say in
Isaiah 6 5-7 that the sarap took a
burning flaming hot coal touched your
mouth and that coal purged your mouth of
its
uncleanliness and purified you of your
sin and I said woe is me for I am lost
for I a man of unclean lips and I dwell
in the midst of a people of unclean lips
for my eyes have seen the king the Lord
of hosts see without Holiness you cannot
see the Lord and he realizes I'm seeing
God and I'm unworthy I'm unclean I'm
sinful so what did God do he could have
just said I removed your sin right why
didn't God simply say to Isaiah your
sins are
removed because in Isaiah 53 you'll
prophesy the servant will come and I
will lay your sins on him he'll bear
your sins and offer his soul as a guilt
offering to forgive you and make
atonement for you and intercede for you
look what he does wo is me for I'm a man
of unclean lips and I dwell in the midst
of people of unclean lips for my eyes
have seen the king the Lord of hosts now
watch what he does then flew one of the
Ser to me having in his hand a burning
coal which we had taken with tongues
from the altar now it's a burn burning
hot flaming coal touch a cold you burn
right but he touched his mouth with it
and he didn't feel any pain he wasn't
burned he was purged wasn't
burned and he touched my mouth and said
behold this has touched your lips your
guilt is taken away and your sin
forgiven if Purgatory nullifies the
perfect work of the Lord Jesus Christ
and blasphemes his
Perfection then why do you find Isaiah 6
instead of God saying your sin is
removed a burning coal touches his mouth
physically and that coal then purifies
purges his purges Isaiah of his sin and
his unclean mouth even though Isaiah
will be the one who prophesied in Isaiah
53 the servant will come and the Lord
will lay on him the iniquity of us all
and he'll bear up the sins of many and
make intercession for
Sinners do you understand now
how this establishes that Purgatory does
not nullify the work of Christ does not
slander Christ or Rob him of his
Perfection as a perfect savior who
perfectly saves and procures your
forgiveness but that purgation is
included in his work it's because of his
death that now you're given the grace of
purgation and you see how this purgation
didn't hurt Isaiah didn't harm Isaiah
but cleansed Isaiah and he felt no pain
who would have thought Isaiah 65 to7
would show you how Purgatory is
compatible with Jesus's work as Savior
and doesn't contradict it